as we are all set to go the roof is open
as you say is up on the mount of the
mariners in their sunday cream alternate
uniforms
and there's strike three on marta two
quick outs left-handers o2 coming home
swing in a miss for strike three and
there's the gas at 95. he saved it for
his final pitch at the top of the first
he strikes out marshall pitcher for the
diamondbacks today the lefty tyler
gilbert who pitched seven innings in a
no decision against the seattle lineup
last sunday at chase field
13th pitch to france right here again
that one popped up got him on a splitter
to the right side of the infield the
second baseman young has it makes the
catch
did he go he did since home played up by
ron kulper three consecutive strikeouts
and this would be a tag right here to
dispose of david peralta four
consecutive strikeouts two down second
inning rio pitch
poor pitch walk
[Applause]
back door cutter got it through there
and gilbert gets his first
that strikeout barrels one up to center
and it gets to the wall seth beers debut
continues what a series he's had in
seattle here's josh van meter it's a
rare start against a lefty for van meter
this season josh has been a little bit
of a funk seven for his last 47.
let's hit hard and into center van meter
gets the diamondbacks on the board it's
one nothing
bidding for one more right here backs up
martay in center cattell runs it down
into the wall
jared kelner gave it a ride martay had
just enough room that time and it's
allowed out number one
chase that high fastball and gilbert
gets his second strikeout and a one two
three third one two pitch
strike three called five strikeouts for
kikuchi
trying to butt his way on he got it by
kikuchi
and dalton varsio
with that head first slide into first as
a bunk base hit
walker
punches one into right field varsity
will have to stop at second couple of
one-out singles
3-1 is low and they're loaded with one
out for henry ramos
swing and a miss he got it that's a big
one six strikeout
two outs bases loaded behind one two
here's the pitch
check swing and he goes 95 mile an hour
fastball he pins it in on his knuckles
and beer can't help but go around
diamondbacks leave the mariners one
nothing we go to the bottom of the
fourth here's mitch haniger
flat ball center field mark tay giving
ground on the trigger
32nd home run
79th rbi that baby was stung
the smasher has a base hit round single
into right center gets us started in the
fifth inning
one more that gets under the glove of
toro ombed just kind of pokes it through
there and then meters in at second
one two pitch
swinging in ole miss got him for the
third time
down goes martay two outs to set the
pitch swinging a weak round ball off the
end of the bat it's a fair ball over the
back at third taken by seeger who races
over third base stomps on the bag and
they get the force on van meter
tamasevich will take over on the hill
for the m's
and is belted through into left the
lead-off single for christian who's two
for three
[Applause]
and peralta hits one down the line it's
headed for the corner and walker's on
the move
they'll stop him at third it's a double
for the freight train good start to the
sixth a chance for henry ramos who has
grounded out and struck out he's over
two
ramos belts it into left field walker is
home peralta right behind henry robots
the two-run double and it's three-to-one
diamondbacks
they are jumping all over anthony
macevic
and now it's seth beard beard doubled
and scored in the third struck out his
last time up
seth beer sends one to right field
another hit for bear almost comes around
since beer the rbi
and it's 4-1 diamondbacks buddy ring the
bell time to get some offense going here
dylan moore leads off tyler gilbert's
got a little breathing room high drive
deep left field that baby's gone
that's how you ring the bell
for two ball game demo
dylan moore with his 12th home run rbi
number 40. good start to the mariners
six call to the bullpen this is the move
that toy lavello made in the seventh
inning last night brought on sean poppin
to face mitch haniker and poppin struck
him out to end the inning hopkins pitch
that's low ball four mitch hanigar draws
the walk and ty france will be the tying
run here in the sixth inning 3-2 pitch
the other way young over to peralta
throws it away there's a break
oh that sets up nicely now you got to
cash it in
deep to center cattell martay has got it
at the wall
runners were halfway they'll have to
hurry back
aguilar worked the scoreless inning
friday in the opener against seattle
it's to toro takes for ball for the load
it up for luis terrence
drop the shortstop van meter in front of
ahmed and aguilar walked toro but he got
out of it and now it's going to tell
martay who has had three terrible
advance in the ball game today
could tell martay tees off and sends it
way out of here
well that's how you break out of a
losing skid
three at bats three strikeouts and
there's the home run and it's five to
two
off the glove peralta make that ahmed
and a good slide there
what a play by josh van meter makes up
for that e5 takes a base hit away
and gets us to the ninth inning paul to
the bullpen jb scoreless baseball in
seven of his last eight appearances
including a one two three ninth last
night
slow rollerblade meter
bare hand get nothing base hit
kelly go for two of the walk been some
magic moments for the mariners they
could use one here three or two to
kelnick do it again
high drive right field that baby's gone
there's a magic moment we got a one run
ball game in the ninth
jk goes deep home run number ten what a
spot
nine pitches in the at-bat
it's a fastball is pretty much in the
middle of play but elevated 94 miles an
hour and rides it out of here
a little tapper when delkins there
diamondbacks get the win five for the
final they win a road series
for the first time since the end of
april in atlanta
[Applause]